le théâtre d'anton tchekhov est parfois
perçue comme arid est lourd il peut
faire peur mais rené richard cyr
confondre les sceptiques qui est en fait
un portraitiste incroyable pour certains
auteurs encore qui sonne des cloches et
clisson nouveaux poteaux jours on peut
pas dire que cette actuelle on peut dire
que cet éternel
la pièce se déroule dans un petit
village isolé de la steppe russe ou
trois soeurs aux caractères bien
différents partagent le désir de
majorque où la vie serait plus heureuse
et reina qui est la jeunesse et la joie
de vivre
olga qui plutôt qui a pris le rôle un
peu plus résignés de l'aîné et mekki qui
est travaillée antilles qui s'occupe des
autres
macha qu'il a passionné la fougueuse à
18 ans la pièce originale dure plus de
trois heures la datation présentée au
tnm la condenser en une heure trente
sans en sacrifier les sens les questions
de pourquoi la vie la perte des
illusions
le désir de se dépasser le désir d'un
monde meilleur
pourquoi on laisse tomber nos illusions
mais en même temps beaucoup d'humour a
d'ailleurs beaucoup ce qui crée avec
énormément de bienveillant
la troupe réussi à mettre en valeur
toute l'humanité de l'oeuvre je trouve
vraiment beau c'était on sent un vrai
lien entre les trois soeurs qui les unit
qui met mal guérisseur tout le monde
sait sans sel à certains égards c'est
également une pièce aux accents féminins
j'ai l'impression aussi que les femmes
au fil des siècles pas de par leur
dépendance à des réalités extérieurs à
leurs champs de pouvoir elle devait être
solidaire donc au delà de leur lien
familial
il ya un lien de sororité encore plus
large que celui des femmes entre elles
les trois soeurs et une pièce sur les
illusions les désillusions et sur
l'espoir ici nabi alexandre chartier
radio-canada monde